so my name is an Erin and today here on
beyond football I have the pleasure of
welcoming you to segment I like to call
the OSE secret or an aldohn all of the
games that are football related
whatsoever each week we'll be pitting
the two best players in the world
against each other on different games
and seeing who comes out on top now
today we've got WWE and what could
possibly go wrong oh my this is
genuinely amazing I can't believe
they're gonna come out in their full
kits as well Cristiano Ronaldo stepped
it out in the WWE match for the shin
pads on you love to see it Chris your
adults will up for this but let's hear
from his rival Greek pronunciation needs
some work but we can move on from that
now what can we expect from this fight a
close Aegean count you could feel the
electricity running for Serena I think
it's fair to say Messi's come straight
out of traps with that one this is
honestly one of the craziest things I've
ever seen as Messi comes in slamming
onto the face of Ronaldo who replies
with a massive forearm
mrs. the stump there but mess he goes in
with all I mean come on Stewie that's
the yellow card offense Messi coming in
here with yet another huge hit before he
gloats in front of our fans didn't do
the shirt off celebration oh that's a
bit disappointing Ronaldo could be in
trouble already here but he's coming
with the reverse our never wearing slum
Messi to the ground oh my goodness me
Messi is getting chucked out of the
entire ring wrong mate is behind you
walk past him he needs that I see why
he's going for the ladder this is not
the time to be clearing out some drain
pipes or Messi's on the ropes that's a
huge hit from ran out the ladders gone
he just spent ages putting that up in
the first place
Messi's in trouble again he's gonna need
something huge took out of this anyhow
this match is all over
place the levers but in this khayrat in
position to win the money but Messi
scales it East back from although twice
three times he grabs it by the head and
throws ins in the canvas Leonel all you
gotta do now is untie the briefcase
you've got it as in unfunny NL for
goodness sake has he got it he's finally
done it
Leo Messi is the winner for today the
bomb on the WWE is run by Messi I'm
still not sure why I've just witnessed
today both
[Music]